foreign
in Columbus Ohio what's up Kaelyn
Hi how are you doing great how about you
um okay
what's up how can I help
Ed to go
um and you told me I could call back
whenever and kind of tell you what's
going on and oh no did I give you did I
give you bad advice
for that at all to be honest okay all
right cool well so what's up yeah
so my question is how can I support my
spouse in the aftermath of my Mental
Health crisis
give me some more contacts what happened
oh
um so
almost three weeks
three weeks it's admitted to a
psychiatric crisis stabilization
Hospital on an in-law I'm sorry 72 hour
hold
oh man dude that means you were acutely
suicidal what happened
I yeah I just didn't want to be alive
anymore yeah
um
they I've been depressed for a while
this summer and so my doctor increased
the medication I was on and I think it
was the wrong medication for my body
because a week after the medication
everything just got like 100 times worse
and it just felt like I was gonna hold
it I could never crawl out of
so I went to the hospital I've actually
heard I've actually heard it the other
way
um where
when they ratchet up your meds a lot
in an acute setting
it actually takes somebody who's in a
black hole and gives them just enough
gumption to cash out
yeah you see what I'm saying
instead of pulling it deeper down the
rabbit hole it actually pulls you up
where you can see just a little bit I
can just reach to the top of the counter
too
go ahead and get off this train
yeah
so things are bad yeah let's back out
why did you call the show originally
the first one
um about my mom asking me for money
and feeling like resentful towards her
so yeah it's not really they're actually
related to that well but I mean
I'm just trying to get a context for
your depression but that's not really
why you're calling so let's get let's
get to yeah the call so number one I'm
so
so glad that you're alive
thank you are you
most of the time
okay I'll take that as a win right now
yeah
um
um do you I know when you're sitting in
a black hole and you feel tired
and you feel like I'm out
do you also feel like people would be
better off without you around
yeah I'm gonna yeah and I have like more
contact for that okay tell me more about
that
um so especially after
um coming home from the hospital
um
I think if it's been like crazy
um when I was in the hospital my mom
wanted to see me and I didn't want to
see her just because like she's causing
so much stress
um so my husband had to kind of relay
that information
and it didn't go over very well my mom
basically told my whole family that my
husband is abusive and manipulative and
keeping me from her
and so like no one is talking to my
husband and it's like I just feel so
horrible because I like created this
mess
I'm a challenge at heart is that cool
yeah okay you play no role in this
your husband did exactly what he was
supposed to do which is stand between
you any sort of danger coming your way
yeah and that was your mom
God bless your husband dude good for him
he stood down a dragon and that Dragon
couldn't do anything to him because he's
a strong man and he loves you so she
went and burned down everything else in
the neighborhood
yeah all of your safety nets all your
relationships all the people you reach
out to his reputation all of it that is
not you Galen
you're separate from that in fact
she's been trying to drag you underwater
with her for years
yeah and you've kept fighting
because that's who you are you're so
strong and you don't even see it
and then you married an amazing guy who
will stand shoulder to shoulder with you
and say let's do this together
yeah right
yeah
so I want you to hear I know how you
feel
I trust you and you tell me how you feel
I'm asking you to trust me when I tell
you how you feel is not reality
reality is you're a very strong woman
who
um is a core part of your husband's life
or he wouldn't stand in front of the
fire for you
and vice versa right
so when it feels heavy and dark
challenge that feeling because it's not
true
I'm heartbroken that your mom treats you
like this and treats him like this
it's truly heartbreaking
yeah so I called my mom
um last week or the week before
um and basically told her like this is
not my husband this is
um and I hadn't had like a conversation
with her like this so I I don't know but
I just said like right now you are
causing me anxiety being around you
makes me stressed out because I'm just
so worried about your financial
situation all the time and I need to
focus on getting better and healing
right now and so I need space from you
and it seemed to go okay but she keeps
like messaging my husband like I'm so
sad when can I see Kailyn again okay but
listen this I want to give you some
content this is bigger than money
yeah your mom has used you for your
entire life to prop her up whether that
was emotional psychological Financial
and now she's trying to use you again to
make her feel better because you're in
the hospital
yeah that's insane
your job in your lowest moments when
you're hurting when you're surrounded by
Medical Care Professionals your job is
not to make her feel better
she's a grown woman that's her job in
her community that she should have
surrounding her
but she's used you as a life raft and
that was never your job you're her
daughter
can I just tell you how
out of this world proud of you I am for
having that conversation with her
thank you like that's a that's not a
little win
so after you get out of this out of of
an involuntary hold here's the goal
little wins
yeah right I want you just to shower
today and you can get back in bed have
you all had those conversations I just
want you have one meal and you get back
in bed have you all walked through that
yeah okay and I'm actually back at work
downstairs though excellent actually
yeah
but a big win is
you calling the dragon and saying hey
you are a prop part of this problem here
and I am going I value my
health and my body and my personality
and my marriage so much that I am
building a wall between us
dude that is that takes a long time for
someone to get the strength and courage
to do that I I can't tell you how proud
of you I am for that it's amazing
can you do me a favor
yeah wherever you're sitting will you
stand up like real tall don't get up
just like put your back straight and I
want you to like take your shoulders and
clench them up real tight around your
ears just do it for like two seconds one
two and then drop them
like
you did that
like for real
yeah
and I know it hurt and you hung up the
phone and probably felt guilty and
patted oh my gosh what's gonna happen
I'm so proud of you okay so we're now
we're back and now my guess is your
husband
is hovering over you like a umbrella
like an Ella
yes and I know it's because he loves
seeing his words but it's like just
constant you know like he's just so
panicked that I'm gonna do something
stupid and I get it but are you going to
it feels like a lot I don't think so
nope that's not a good answer
okay no okay
are you saying that just to shut me up
no okay
if there's any any crack in that
concrete he's going to do what he can to
cover it up
as he should
yeah as any of us who love our wives
would do
what you'll have to work through right
now is the the development of a plan
that is Ironclad that you will stick to
and that he will stick to and that your
medical professionals will stick to what
does that mean
I need you can text me four times a day
all these texts are stressing me out
but I also know that you love me and I
love you and I need that connection so
we're gonna agree to text four times a
day
we're going to agree to SOS skin on skin
contact four times a day right when we
wake up we're gonna stay in bed an extra
two minutes and just hold hands and
touch feet
yeah I'm gonna see what I'm saying like
we're gonna come up with a plan and
we're gonna you especially Kayla are
gonna stick to that plan Like Glue
okay and that's going to slowly
slowly
release his grip on
okay she's safe
she's safe
yeah the woman who I pledged my whole
life to is safe
now I can breathe too
yeah
right does it make you uncomfortable
that he loves you that much
no okay
when you're in the black hole though you
feel like his life would be better if
you were gone didn't you
yeah
yeah why is that
okay that's okay
um
I don't know I feel like
I just don't like add anything to anyone
like I don't like
add value to anything
yeah
as I said earlier I will I will honor
the fact that that's your feeling
all of the evidence that you've given me
is to the contrary
and it's important to remember this one
thing feelings are not designed to tell
us the truth that's not their job their
job is to keep us safe
and so like when a soccer ball rolls
into the street and my son goes to get
it and I scream you're gonna die
probably not gonna die
but my job is to keep them alive right
not to tell them the truth in that
moment
similarly that's your body's telling you
like hey here's somebody else who love
said they love us the last time somebody
said they loved us
they were a vampire
they try to take everything
and this guy sounds like he's for real
is he for real
so the next time you feel like you don't
add any value
I want you to remember this conversation
and once you remember that guy
who right now you are so annoyed that he
is so close to you all the time because
he loves you that much
do I have your solemn promise that if
you ever get
um feeling like you want to hurt
yourself again that you'll call somebody
yeah
say I solemnly promise
I solemnly promise okay you you can't
lie against a podcast or a YouTube show
that's like uh Cosmic or something okay
okay I think here it like in all honesty
the conversation goes like this with
your husband
um I'm home for two weeks I'm home for
three weeks
I can tell you can't breathe which then
makes me not breathe with which then
makes you not breathe and so yeah this
is our reality
and you look him in the eye and you hold
both of his hands and you say I will
never
hurt myself again
ever
and I want you to say it with conviction
and mean it and if you don't believe
that then you gotta call your
psychiatrist and your counselor right
away you promise
yeah okay
I'm having a hard time believing you
right now
okay well part of it is because
it's hard when people say like
hurt yourself because I don't know if
you mean like self-harm or suicide or
both both
okay
because you have to stop cutting too
I know
that that that that that build up inside
builds up and builds up and builds up
and that's that ultimate fatigue I'm
just done
yeah
you know what I mean
yeah and can you tell I've had this
conversation a whole bunch in my life
yeah
but you've got to go sit with somebody
and say I want to stop cutting
which in and of itself I didn't even get
my heart rate up that doesn't bother me
but when you attach that to this idea
that
um I'm slowly kind of sort of ish
practicing
and so if you're gonna hurt yourself or
if you're going to take your life
you have to make that call
yeah
everybody's life around using Ash
if you're not here
yeah my counselor keeps telling me
um
like I said like I feel like all of this
mess wouldn't have happened if I just
killed myself and she was like Caitlin
it would just be like 100 times worse
what are you talking about it would be
infinitely worse
infinitely worse and I don't care about
them right now I care about you
you wouldn't be here
and my children would miss out on the
contribution you're going to add to the
world
I don't want that world
okay
yeah and I know it doesn't feel like you
add a contribution to it that's where
the work is
and so you hear me do you trust me
yeah okay
so you hear me saying what I'm saying
and you don't feel that what I'm saying
registers as truth and I get that
instead of being scared by that say huh
I gotta figure out how to build a bridge
to that
because I trust that guy even when I
don't trust me I trust that guy I trust
my counselor even I don't trust me I
trust my husband even I don't trust me
so how do I build a bridge to get there
and that's what your counselor helps you
do
and it's about learning some new skills
that's it you got a tool kit and all you
have in it is a razor blade
and a bottle of pills right
yeah yes cool let's get some new tools
because the pain you feel is real the
home you grew up in was a chaotic mess
we're gonna get some new tools
we're gonna learn to exercise and you're
like no yup it has to happen
or you can learn to go for a walk with
your husband every day
you're gonna learn to turn Electronics
off and not just spin out and spin out
and spin out and spin out
you can learn to have people over to
your house and hang out
there's just skills
they're not crazy things for crazy
people who got talents that you didn't
get just skills
what do you do for a living
I miss teacher oh my gosh you've learned
that skill
foreign
what grade do you teach
I teach fourth they're the best
and did you know your room of 25 little
fourth graders goes homes to their
parents every night and tells them how
much they love Miss Caitlin
I think so
they all do even the ones they don't
like you do
because you know
what some of them are going through in
their homes
yeah and you know that some of them look
in the mirror don't like what they see
and you know what that feels like
and you know that some of them sit in
that classroom and wish they could just
disappear in their own seat and they
can't
and that makes you
that makes you the dream dream teacher
I'm good at my job I know you are I just
want you to love yourself as much as
those fourth graders love you
at least Fair
yeah fair so you're not leaving me
you're not leaving those kids you're not
leaving your knucklehead husband who
loves you so much
and you've already taken the awesome
first hard step of not leaving but just
separating yourself from
people who hurt you cool
yeah and we're done with cutting
and we're going to find some alternative
behaviors there
okay okay
you got no more reason to punish Kayla
and Caitlyn's pretty awesome
cool
yeah
so let's make a plan with husband in a
very detailed plan almost like a fourth
grade like like you would give to your
fourth graders at eight o'clock is when
we hug and at 10 15 is when I have a
break and I'll text you say how much I
love you and at noon I will text you and
at this time I'll text you in a dinner
we will do this
and if I
end up cutting in my car out in the
parking lot before school starts my
promise is I will call this counselor
and I will call you
if I start feeling like I don't want to
be here anymore and I'm going to take my
life I will call this person and I will
call this person and I will call you
you have my solemn word promise
and we will begin to take a walk
together before school starts and in the
evening
and we'll get a dog and we'll fill in
the blank but y'all come up with a plan
together so that he can exhale a little
bit which will allow you to Exhale a
little bit which will allow him to
Exhale a little bit and takes all of the
smoke out of your house
you just gotta practice it and I
honestly recommend that y'all you and
him go to your counselor and say hey we
want to make a safety plan for our home
so that we can all breathe in here
and your counselor probably smile real
big and too I got you on that one
so so so grateful you're here Kayla you
again call anytime call next week we'll
have you back on
so glad that you're here
foreign